been eating about three prunes after dinner to help with elimination.
I also do daily coffee animals are the prunes okay since they're fairly sweet.
Or do you recommend a different gentle option?
No, I do recommend prunes.
And in your binder, remember you have a page that I might have changed the name of it,
use to call it constipation, know how that goes over different things that you could do
to help with elimination.
I would say prunes are working.
That's a food.
And so I would just do that.
The other sort of things are that would be mild things to help with elimination
would be magnesium, taking magnesium before bed.
That can help.
Yeah, but if prunes are working, then I would just stay with the prunes.
If all else fails in a person is extremely constipated there, having a difficult time,
having a ball of wood, then I tell people to go to the, that the super-allow,
which is an ortho molecular product.
It's you can do the super-allow 250 or the super-allow 450.
Now people will just say, well, it's just aloe.
I have aloe at home.
I'll use it.
Or I think I have aloe capsules, you know, or a liquid aloe playup.
Understand, there's different varieties of the aloe playup.
So typically the aloe that you would have in a capsule or a liquid at home to help heal
the gut is called aloe arboressence.
So that's not the aloe that we're talking about.
This is called cape aloe.
That's a totally different variety of aloe.
And what it does is it causes stimulation of your smooth muscles, your testons.
And it will just literally flush you out.
So I've not had a person that has been constipated that super-allow did not work on it.
So cape aloe is the product that we're talking about.
It's cape aloe.
So cape aloe could be found in the super-allow 250 to super-allow 450.
We have it in a so 250 stands for milligrams per council 450 as milligrams per council.
We have it a much smaller dose in our, I think it's our phase six or phase six assist.
So one of the other ones where it's only like 50 milligrams doses, just so it would be for a person who's not constipated but wants to just stay regular.
Typically people don't use high dose cape aloe.
And I would say even 250 milligrams is relatively high dose.
Typically, typically people don't use that high of a dose of cape aloe just on a daily basis.
Typically people are using a much lower dose.
And we have it in some other products too so you can look up cape aloe.
But I would definitely stay with prunes or magnesium as my first choices.
And then we have a lot of patients that will have a bottle of super-allow in their cupboard so that,
gosh, I didn't go at all yesterday. I feel like I'm bloated. I feel like I need to really clean myself out that they'll use the super-allow.
Now, understand, I do have a number of people that use the super-allow 250 on a daily basis.
And they are just happier than a lot because they feel like they're cleaning out on a daily basis.
And I'm totally okay with that. There isn't any no negative effects of using it on a daily basis.
But usually people don't need to.
Now remember, you have the seven phases of detoxification course available to you too.
So do look at that. And phase six is proper elimination.
So I do have that data, more information about super-allow and things in that.
And other, and I do have, if you can't find your binder, I do have that constipation know how information in that phase, in that part of the seven phases of detoxification course as well.
So you'll find more information than what I'm talking about right here.